well congratulations to the class of
2014 the most indebted college
graduation class in history Wall Street
Journal reporting as college graduates
in the 2014 class prepare to shift to
their tassels and accept their diplomas
they leave school with one discouraging
distinction the most indebted class ever
that's just crazy when you think about
it man
I mean Wow trillions and trillions the
average class of 2014 graduate with
student loan debt has to pay back some
$33,000 even after adjusting for
inflation that's nearly double the
amount borrows paid back 20 years ago
meanwhile a greater share of the
students taking on debt to finance
higher education a little over 70
percent of this year's bachelor's degree
recipients are leaving school with
student loans up from about half in 1994
the problem developing is that earnings
and debt aren't moving in the same
direction from 20 from 2005 to 2012 the
average student loan debt jumped 35%
adjusted for inflation while the median
salary dropped 2.2 percent okay so what
we do well we learn about college isn't
that interesting
he'd learn about college now I just had
my third one graduate the other day he's
class of 2014
obviously he graduated debt-free that
would be ridiculous be like me taking
out a credit card but so third of hours
to do that let me help you with this one
of the things we wrote about wrote an
entire chapter on college debt and and
how to avoid it it's too late for 2014
you guys got to figure it out let me
stop there though for just a second I
did a commencement address
I should did my son's commencement
address I was honored to get to be at my
own school of University of Tennessee
that was a great honor but then add to
that my son was actually walking that
day and so pretty cool milestone in that
commencement address I told those young
people two things that you need to hear
if you're coming out in 2014 or you came
out in 2015 and you're a victim of these
statistics by the way you're not a
victim
you made choices thing number one you
need to know is this you are entitled to
nothing nothing this culture owes you
nothing as a matter of fact if you went
to a state school your tuition was
subsidized by this taxpayers in that
state you owe them you owe society a
debt for your education you're entitled
to nothing let me tell you what you do
have you do have the best possible time
to have graduated and enter the business
world in the history of mankind oh I
know the statistics say that the college
rates are going up at thirty five
percent and the average salary is only
up 2.2 percent so maybe you decide not
to be average because let me just tell
you if you want to launch a business you
want to be in business you want to
market something you want to find a way
to serve your culture and help people
and by the way they will pay you when
you help them with a problem they will
pay you when they help them that was
something that's not even a problem if
you just help people they pay you they
always give you these certificates of
appreciation when you help them it's got
a president's faces on them they're
green and kind of rectangular when you
help people that's what happens you make
money so find a way to serve in the
culture but I mean you technology as at
its zenith right now
it's it's in its in crazy mode the
things you can access the speed with
which you can access information the
speed and ease and and the cost with
which you can access customers by the
bazillions I mean I have five hundred
and forty thousand people follow me on
Twitter that means if I have a thought
and can capture it in 140 characters I
can tell five hundred forty thousand
people that instantaneously and it's
free seven years ago that didn't even
exist 2.2 million people follow me on
Facebook you know what that cost me
nothing you know Craig
this cost you nothing you know YouTube
cost you nothing you know an Instagram
and Pinterest cost you nothing
you know what the web access cost you
nothing except your connectivity fee you
have the world in your stinking hands I
mean when I came out of school I'll go
ahead even invented the Internet people
it wasn't time yet you have the best
time to bring a product to market to
serve your fellow man and a cheaper cost
at a faster rate than any time in the
history of humankind that's what you
just graduated into freakin opportunity
coming out your ears but you are
entitled to nothing you have the right
to pursue happiness now how do we go to
school if we're not 2014 let's say we're
2020 maybe we're seniors or juniors how
do you go to school and not be one of
these student loan ridden people they
come out with this stuff hanging around
their neck and I'm not talking about
cords from graduating well I'm talking
about weights well the first and
foremost reason that people going to
student loan debt is they select a
college they cannot afford go to a
school you can afford shut up I don't
really want to hear it go to a school
you can afford period if you start two
years in a Community College if you go
to end state if you live in your mama's
basement while you go in state you keep
the cost down to a I don't if you if you
have a bazillion dollars and your
daddy's a billionaire and you want to go
to the school you can afford that's any
school go I got a friend of Mines got
his kid in private school cost about a
hundred grand a year and he can afford
it and that's fine
I don't have any issue with that at all
I really don't whatever wherever you
want to go but you pay for it and you
parents your job is to parent and that
includes 18 year olds who are picking
out $200,000 worth of tuition they can't
afford at some stinking school because
their boyfriend's going there
this is stupid and it's cause you
parents are parenting love your children
well enough to participate in the
decision and demand in order to get your
involvement in the decision that they
make good decisions that they can afford
college selection is number one number
two is get a job while you're in school
won't hurt you it's not child abuse
number three is apply for four thousand
scholarships you will get turned down
for most of them and the rest of them
will give you money for free
see there's ways to do this folks
without a student loan Oh while you're
in school live in the dorm you don't
need to live in a apartment with a
jacuzzi and a skylight a racquetball
court give me a break you're a college
student this is the Dave Ramsey show
you